so hey everybody had a little Mike
trouble on this one sound quality is not
going to be up to usual standard sorry
you know it's kind of a shame that
Marvel did the whole viral we didn't
start the fire thing because really the
Game of Thrones cast really should have
done one Game of Thrones penultimate
episode of the entire show second to
last time we will see these characters
and this might go up a little bit later
than usual because I'm recording it the
morning after instead of immediately
after I'm kind of glad I did that I did
that actually because I was just tired
and needed to go to bed but it gave me
the chance to sort of literally sleep on
it and think a little bit more and
gather my feelings because they are kind
of mixed and a little bit all over the
place and I'm still trying to assess how
much I do or don't like this episode
here's the thing it's not a slam dunk
either way if I like it it's with
reservations if I don't like it it's
with acknowledgments of merits so it's
I'm going back and forth on that okay
let me just start talking through this I
think well at least the impression I get
overall is that not many people are
actually thrilled with the season but
the reason people don't like the this
season seems to vary on a case by case
basis in other words it seems to be
pleasing nobody or at least up until
this episode I haven't checked the
reaction on this episode maybe this one
was a slam dunk dump for people but if I
were to put an underlying fundamental
issue with the season as a whole it's
that too many character and large-scale
plot lines were left to be closed in to
smallest space there they probably
should have closed out a few more
characters resolve their plots in some
earlier seasons because one of the
nagging feelings I have about the season
as a whole is that a lot of stuff feels
a bit rushed
and on the one hand I'm like but there's
eight seasons worth of buildup but on
the other hand I'm going well it's not
so much that it's Russia's that it has
to share space with the closing out of
all these other plots as well and it
feels like at least partially these
episodes this one in particular was
written with a checklist of plot threads
that had to be dealt with and they're
trying to clear off as many as possible
there's seven named character deaths
that I can remember I thought my head I
might even be missing one or two so that
that does feel like a kind of a hurried
wrap-up even though the build for most
of these plots has been slow moving as
it's come forward I suppose I'll touch
on the character desk because I know
what I'm gonna spend the most time
talking about so in terms of character
deaths Jamie and Cersei which I'd
probably keep pronouncing it wrong I
change how I pronounce it like every
time I say it I'm sorry just work with
me here um the two of them it it was
fitting it wasn't especially satisfying
then again I'm not sure it was supposed
to be the thing is though unsatisfying
endings for characters I think are
easier to get away with when you know
there's gonna be a lot more show coming
so like the red wedding haha I like wow
it was tragic but it was also kind of an
unsatisfying conclusion for a fair
number of characters but also there was
gonna be so much more after that so it
kind of gave you a chance to reassess
you know what your investment in the
show was that's not the case here so
when something closes out not quite
satisfactorily it leaves a little bit
more of a bitter taste in your mouth and
I don't think what happened with the two
of them was bad and again it made sense
it just felt a little anticlimactic
and I was wrong I I've been calling for
ages that Jamie was gonna kill her he
was going to be pushed to the point that
he had to and he didn't they did die
together though so there's that Qyburn
oh he went down hard and fast just throw
okay we got cleganebowl which was that
work that went pretty well
like for something that has been built
up for as long as that has that could
have been really an underperformer I
kind of went again I kind of wish you
didn't have to share space with
everything else going on and I kind of
wish you could have been a fight a bit
more like the Viper in the mountain
where it was a long continuous thing
where we see the progress of this fight
as opposed this thing where we kept
cutting back to it and had to keep going
to other stuff that said the fight when
we were cutting back to it it went
pretty well and while part of me is like
oh would like the loss of the Hound that
in that case both of them dying feels
more satisfying because like the Hound
kind of had accepted the fact that his
mmm his single-minded pursuit of revenge
was going to ultimately get him killed
he just wanted to be sure that when it
did he also got the revenge she was
after so like I can roll with that I'm
kind of okay with that um God who else
was there
Oh baris that that one was also kind of
unsatisfying it again it makes sense
it's logical but again because that
happens like right at the start it does
feel like they're just burning off
burning off the the character it did to
just close him out and be done with him
because you know his concerns about
Cersei were to the point that well he
he's not gonna stick around and then
there was your on who I was happy to see
go because I was just kind of done with
him at this point like he was fun
briefly like a season two seasons ago
maybe but ya know I was kind of done
with him so that that was fine and
that's all the named characters that I
can recall at at this point being killed
as I said I might have missed one or two
but the major thing that sort of has
been occupying my brain so the rise of
Mad Queen Daenerys I'm going back and
forth in my head as to how well they've
actually pulled this off there's
something in my gut that just isn't
quite all on board with it and I've had
thankfully I've had a night's sleep and
he's sort of waking up and thinking
about it more to sort of come to terms
with why
this working because I see what they're
going but they're basically trying to
pull a Walter White where you know this
entire show I mean not all that it's
been about but her arc has been her
becoming a monster and I can't say that
they haven't put the work in I do think
there have been a few leaps in the last
couple episodes though and also part of
this transition depends on a plot point
that I don't buy so in terms of overall
progress
I remember complaining like in earlier
seasons will they decide is she a good
leader or not but that wavering back and
forth makes more sense now if this was
always the endgame because she had to
display enough instability that this
would be believable but she had to
display enough potential stability that
people would continue to follow her so
she could get to this point so like
trying to balance that for as long as
they as they kept this thing going I can
see why she kind of wavered up and down
in in my estimation over the course of
the show as much as she did
but again that said I feel like that
there have been a couple of leaps so
like I I was talking with Liz about some
of this and like she said she said that
she felt the burning of of the father
and son the tarly's last season was kind
of the the turning point for her and I
kind of cocked my head and go I'm not
sure that it was like it was it was
unnecessary it was kind of cruel but
there was also a logic to it which was
that these were these were your enemies
they're not bending the knee she could
show mercy or she couldn't or she could
take them out she chose to take them out
was that the cruel choice of those
choices yes but it was still a logical
choice given who they were in the
situation that she was in what she's
doing now we're we literally hear her
thought process is she will burn this
city to the ground and be totally fine
annihilating thousands of innocent
people because she'll save future
generations from oppression like we've
gone
from a logical but cruel choice to a
completely faulty set of logic so it's
like her entire thought process
mechanism has broken down in a way that
to me again feels like a bit of a leap
and I know there's contributing factors
to this there's the loss of misandry
which like I get it I just did that I
actually forgot to mention that in my
review of the previous episode because
she's always she's not a character
everyone particularly latched on to but
obviously if an heiress did so it was
important to her so that's a factor you
know with Varys betraying her she
probably has lost faith in Tara and she
she everything that's going on with John
but that's another problem which is I
don't buy the romance between her and
John I'm not sure how much of that is a
writing problem and how much of that
it's just the fact that these two actors
do not have any chemistry together they
just don't
especially when I have Daenerys and oh
my god and Drogo and John and egrets for
comparison I can compare the times that
these actors had chemistry with someone
that I look at the two of them together
I might know so on paper I get how this
has damaged her feeling about people
that it's a contributing factor but
again it doesn't help that I don't care
and have no investment and don't really
buy that relationship so I feel like in
a lot of ways on paper they've done the
work necessary to to sell this whole
thing of her basically being the being
the very clearly the ancestor of the oh
sorry not as the descendant of the man
King she basically does what he was
trying to do and like I I can't send it
into the work but I feel like there were
points of which the work that they did
was like cc- grade some of it was be an
A but like some of it yeah so that the
end result doesn't feel as properly
earned as it should when I like actually
break it down and look at what they've
been doing over the last few seasons so
it's it's left me a kind of an odd place
that said
the more I think about it the more I've
kind of warmed to it I'm not sure I'll
ever completely warm to this thing
because I think there's just been
execution issues along the way but I
think I can recognize enough of what
they were trying to do and the things
that didn't quite click aren't massive
and probably don't even exist for
everybody there's probably people that
buy that relationship between those two
Haeckel a lot more than I do and if you
do it probably helps it probably people
like Miss nd a lot better than I do that
probably helps sell this to you so for
me there's things like that that make it
harder for me to swallow well at the
same time I'm not just going no don't
buy it so it's been an odd thing oh
there is one other thing that did strike
me as odd and again I it feels like an
overstep in terms of the degree of her
homicidal nature which is that I would
have thought once she made her decision
screw it I don't care that they
surrendered that she would have made a
beeline for the Red Keep and immediately
leveled that rather than going for the
city going for and like I'm not saying
that she wouldn't also burnt light so in
my mind what would have worked better if
she went immediately for the red key to
take out seriously believed that she did
that you can still have Cersei die with
Jaime she doesn't have to die into
destruction to keep G you can have her
get out but have that be Daenerys his
initial target realize that that did not
slake her bloodlust did not satisfy her
need for vengeance and her twisted idea
of justice and then go after the
citizens of town doing it the other way
around again feels like way faulty or
logic that I can buy her having at this
point because if they're going for I
want Cersei to have to see the city burn
before she dies I need you to have
Daenerys like say that at some point
that because just knowing what she used
to be not all that long ago that feels
like too much of a leap but I could have
bought it if they'd switched those sort
of targets Ron also how much fire breath
does that dragon have like that thing
goes a while I'm not saying
to adhere to How to Train Your Dragon
rules but I can't help but think back to
that series in where they firmly
established that any given Dragon has a
certain number of shot speed before they
basically need a lie-down in a Gatorade
so that I don't know that's that's
nitpicky at this point so look it was it
was solid it didn't quite work for me
but it's not the falldown of what I felt
the previous episode was and certainly
in terms of selling the battle it looks
I can tell what's going on so that helps
you know versus two episodes ago so I
would say this is this puts the show in
a stronger position for closing out than
what had been done in the previous few
episodes so I'll take that I'll take
that and and I'll be good with it Game
of Thrones you seen the latest episode
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff to do because
there's buttons and links
there's the patreon where you can
support me here and there's also things
like getting on the discord name of the
credits all sorts of stuff check it out
click on that click on merch or don't
you don't have to I'd appreciate it but
at the end of the day folks you're the
council I'm just running the meeting so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]